the latest music news from Selena Gomez  Lana Del Rey and Nicki Minaj why I love  making music is because it affects  people Selena debuted the first listen  of her cover of Yahoo's 1982 hit only  you of the 13 reasons why soundtrack  [Music]  Selena tweeted this revealing it'll be  available on March 30th Lana Del Rey  released this haunting video trailer on  Wednesday revealing her new album lust  for life is coming soon there's no place  I'd rather be than smack dab in the  middle of Hollyweird making this record  for you because you and the music in  this place are my love my life my lust  for life  and Nikki and Gucci Mane premiered their  steamy new make love music video  [Music]